Noël pour moi c'est pas
grand-chose parce que je suis
seule tuis seule au
[Musique]
monde seigneur Jésus je pense à
vous ça prend comme ça il y a pas
d'offense je suis morte de foid je me
tiens plus debout ce soir encore j'ai
pas eu de
chance ce soir par réveillons on est
bien sur le
camionraper des
pouand
mêmeez mon mari qui l'hel couper jamb
suite de
déportation alors depuis le mois de juin
il est à l'hôpital moi j'étais vie jeis
éta à d' Chud et mon sort continue
jusqu'à la mort pourquoi commes tu pas
alors faut voler faut tuer quoi pour
vexer alors tu as vu que j'étais là
avant oui mais rappelle-toi chez nous
les marins bretant on est plus
respectuux que ça hein mais rappelle-toi
que si la prochaine fois tu seras pas
plus po que ça tu pourras recevoir
peut-être les quatre madel et le 4 c'est
la
gueule maises yeux c'est la SA poivre
tout flamb tout Chah tout relui les
restaurants et les bist ils ont la
permission de la
[Musique]
nuit
le
[Musique]
c pas pr
aujourd'hui
la casse toi fait la casse moi je
[Musique]
suis
en toi mais s'il y a de l'air je vous en
réponds
les chez soi
on esté par la chamb du on n pas chaud
mais on fait
[Musique]
pourtant
[Applaudissements]
n
maman j'en sais rien viens dene moi la
main pour aller où je sais rien
bien papa il a une grosse voix tu crois
qu'on saura parler comme ça j'en sais
rien viens de moi la main
Noël pour moi c'est pas
grand-chose parce que je suis
seule je suis seule au
monde comme j'avais le
cafard alors je me suis amuser à
regarder un peu la
jeunesse qui me donne de la guété de
cœur
Antoine qu'est-ce que tu fait Flam
ouais je
plin et ce soir c'est Noël ouis
qu'est-ce que c'est pour toi
Noël pas
grand-chose qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire je ne sais
[Musique]
pas et
demain non
plus 17
ans chouette qui par débir toujours la
femme cherchez vous comprendrez la femme
en principe c'est la femme je me suis
fouté dans le
déboir la séparation donc j'ai tout
bouffé et depuis je suis tombé et ben
j'ai tout mangé évidemment par la menace
de la
femme il y a toujours une haine oui jeis
la peniche à certains
endroits et puis au Château des
Rentiers Nicola
Flamel au baraque c'est l'armée de Salé
Py Laam P c'est juste où je suis
d'ailleurs à
actuelle no c'est rien puis c'est
beaucoup ah bah cette nu j'ai 225 francs
en bochche mon Dieu au diable François
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on prend le métro
merde un
taxi bien beau pr un taxi tu as délopé
toi
no moi c'est lu pour les dames dans le
temps c'est du
[Musique]
chien c'est au son de l'accordéon que
nénette a connu Léon c'est que j'ai
rencontré Fernande
elle était mince elle était grande
cheveux coupés l'air d'un garçon chacun
sa part et sa légende j'ai pris Fernand
au bon moment pour l'héroï d'un
roman mais aujourd'hui je me demande si
c'était vraiment pour
Fernande et non pas pour
l'accordéon
que mon cœur battait pour de bon là où
il se trouve le vin le sommeil les
emporte terrasse vide bouche de métro
pouche d'égout ce matin les poubelles
resteront
[Musique]
intactes